[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So Ken, you
were one of the first Maps API
developers out there, right?
So tell us a bit about that.
KEN HOETMER: I suppose I am.
Yeah, that's true.
So I started developing with
the original Maps API v1 back
in 2005, which actually
only lasted about six months
before the v2 came out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Why
the sudden change?
KEN HOETMER: Why
Well, I think Google wanted to
put some more support behind it
I believe is what happened.
But I remember at
the time, when I
got started with it, that when
you put a marker on a map,
you actually had to
specify the longitude
before the latitude in v1.
And then v2 came
out shortly after.
And I had to change all of my
code to say latitude-longitude.
And it's been
latitude-longitude ever since.
But a few old timers may
remember the days before.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's a great
example of breaking changes,
right?
KEN HOETMER: Breaking
changes, that's right.
That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, I
know also back then you
worked on this-- it
became a pretty famous app
at the time, the Quick Maps?
KEN HOETMER: I
suppose at the time.
At the time, I was just kind
of an independent developer
working out of a
bedroom in Canada.
And I launched an app
I called Quick Maps.
And the tagline was,
Doodle on Google.
And what it let you do
is a bit of a merger
of Microsoft Paint tools--
editing tools-- and Google Maps
API.
And so you could draw on
Google Maps and label things
and save your creations and
send a link to your friends
or put an iframe
on your website.
And it turned out that
this became rather popular.
Nothing like this
existed at the time.
It reached the front page
of Digg and Slashdot.
This was in 2006.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You got Slashdotted?
KEN HOETMER: I got Slashdotted.
And I had been experimenting
with Ruby on Rails
at that time, which was
also a new technology.
And my server collapsed in a
heap at the time on a weekend
when I was away.
And we had to, you know,
fight to get it back up.
But yes, my moment of fame.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But now you're
here of Google working on Maps.
KEN HOETMER: I am, yes.
So at the time--
I guess that was
2006-- I was invited to
interview for an engineering
role at Google, which
I failed miserably.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Don't
worry, I failed twice.
KEN HOETMER: You failed twice?
LAURENCE MORONEY: If at first
you don't succeed, right?
KEN HOETMER: That's right.
Try, try again.
You have second chances.
I'm proof.
I ended up taking a job with
Lonely Planet, a travel company
based in Melbourne,
Australia, at the time working
on digital maps for them.
And in 2011, I became a Googler.
And I joined the Google team as
a product manager, this time.
So if you can't code, you
become a product manager.
And I joined the Google
Maps team then in Sydney.
And I've been there ever
since, as the sandals suggest.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I like it.
You're bringing a bit
of Australia with you.
KEN HOETMER: That's right.
That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you're
working on, what is it?
So it's like the services
for Maps, that type of thing?
KEN HOETMER: So
the Google Maps API
is generally what I work on.
So we have a whole
suite of services now
and the Google Maps API is
beyond-- the original Google
Maps API was a JavaScript API.
But we've since expanded
to Android and iOS
as well as we have a
series of HTTP web services
that folks can use to
develop across platforms.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So like what kind of things
do these services offer?
KEN HOETMER: So maps, of course,
I guess what we're known for.
We're still called the Maps API.
But increasingly as we've moved
into an area that is heavily
driven by mobile and by
connected devices that
are in the world and
know where they are,
the maps are becoming
a secondary piece
to what is more primarily
location information that
is derived from these
devices and making decisions
and building applications
and deriving value
from that location information.
So we've had a few launches
recently along these lines.
One is Places API.
Places API has been
available as a web service
for a number of years.
But last year we launched a
native version of Places API
for Android and iOS.
And Places API does
a number of things.
But for the mobile use case
and the primary use case,
it is, where am I now?
The method is called
Get Current Place, which
would seem obvious, right?
Where am I now?
The device can do that.
It has a GPS.
But the GPS returns a number.
And a number doesn't
mean anything to a user.
And turning that number into
a meaningful label for a user
is actually a very
difficult challenge
and requires access to a
database of place names
that, you know,
not everybody has.
And so we've built
that into Places API.
You can use Places
API to gain access
to Google's knowledge of
places around the world.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And also like
when you get the lat-long back
from a GPS-- I mean, it's
not pinpoint accurate, right?
And there may be
multiple places near you
that you could be
in one of those.
KEN HOETMER: That's right.
So Places API uses a combination
of both latitude and longitude
as well as actually sensing
Wi-Fi signals in the area
to be more accurate,
which is why
it's better to use than, say,
a reverse geocoding call.
We've also launched a new API
called Roads API recently,
as well-- within
the last year or so.
What it does is-- anyone
who's used, I guess, probably
an older GPS tracking app or
has developed with the GPS
on a mobile device knows
that, if you attempt to trace
a route, it bounces, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yup.
KEN HOETMER: It bounces
all over the place
because, well, it
has to go to space
and come back down, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
KEN HOETMER: This is actually
fascinating technology.
But on the way to space
and on the way back down,
you get a jitter.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It
depends on the weather.
KEN HOETMER: It
Of course, right?
So what our Roads
API does is allows
you to pass in a set
of raw GPS lat-longs,
like a raw GPS trace.
And from that we will snap
it to the road network
and give you a normalized
path as well as an identifier
that you can use to interrogate
properties of the road network,
as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
KEN HOETMER: And a
newer feature launched
as well within the last
year-- Directions API
web service has been available
for quite a number of years.
But what we've launched
recently is something
we call predictive travel time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ooh.
KEN HOETMER: Yes.
And with predictive travel
time, what you can do is,
when you ask for directions
between point A and point B,
you can specify
either time equals now
or a time equals
sometime in the future.
And we will give you
an estimate travel time
and actually routes
that we have derived
based on our understanding of
traffic conditions either now
or what they will
be in the future.
And so for folks who are
developing applications
around moving objects--
and the sharing economy
is popping up quite
a lot of these, Uber
being the classic example--
this is a very useful API
for doing logistics
planning, for instance.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So a lot of this,
like, location-based
intelligence,
there must be some
fun use cases.
There must be some great stuff
that people are doing with it.
Can you share any of them?
KEN HOETMER: Yeah.
Well, I mentioned Uber.
Uber is the classic example.
And there are a lot of sort
of Uber-like applications
that we're seeing pop
up around the world.
One of my favorites is
called GO-JEK in Indonesia.
And they are a
similar type service
but for motorcycles
OK Indonesia.
So you can hail a motorcycle
using GO-JEK in Indonesia.
And they're using a
number of our services
to decide which motorcycle
should come to you.
And so you can see which
motorcycle is coming.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And you hop
on the back of the motorbike?
You don't drive it yourself?
KEN HOETMER: That's right.
You hop on the back
of the motorbike.
And it takes you to
where you need to go.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
KEN HOETMER: So another
interesting one,
Dash Labs was our Roads
API launch partner.
And they're using
Roads API, which
snaps GPS traces to
the road network,
to help you with
smarter driving.
And there's a very
fascinating one
in Sydney around the
Directions API feature
I mentioned earlier.
In Sydney, when
you're driving down
the motorway-- in a lot of
cities, you will see this.
There's a sign on the motorway
that says, time to exit 1, 2, 3
is five minutes,
for instance, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
KEN HOETMER: And in
Sydney, this is now not
derived from a sensor
on the road that
is tracking car
movement across the road
but simply by calling our
Directions API for the time
and traffic between
the sign and the exit--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right now.
KEN HOETMER: --right now.
And then they just put
them straight on the sign.
And they've done some
tests before they
launched this feature and proved
that, actually, our Directions
API is as accurate as
the sensors on the road.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
KEN HOETMER: Yeah.
The city of Sydney is
very excited about this
because the cost savings.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
I mean, the cost of like
putting and maintaining
those sensors on the road.
And now what?
The sign itself
just calls an API?
KEN HOETMER: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
That's really cool.
So all of this stuff is
available to developers?
KEN HOETMER: Yes,
developers.google.com/maps.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Easy to remember.
KEN HOETMER: Easy to remember.
And just pick your platform
that you're developing for.
All of our APIs are free to
try, in some cases completely
free depending on your
use cases or with what
we feel are moderate charges
for usage above the limits
should you need it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, sounds good.
So developers.google.com/maps?
KEN HOETMER: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
Well, thanks, Ken.
And thanks, everybody.
If you have any questions
for me or if you
have any questions for
Ken, just please leave them
in the comments below.
And we'll get to them.
And don't forget to subscribe to
the Google Developers channel.